Do too.
And we're live.
We're live with the chat.
We're live.
Well,
the out of the chair.
What's up man?
How are you look better than anybody I've ever seen.
Just a couple of weeks out of shoulder surgery.
I'm a savage man.
You're walking around like there's nothing going on.
They took my savvy stem cells out of my own damn back and he threw him in my
shoulder out of your back.
The hipbone writer.
Fuck bone marrow.
They got in there.
Cintrifuse spun him,
shot him into my shoulder and shit.
I should have a lingo,
but I'm out Tuesday anyway,
so I kind of prematurely decided to come out of the slain.
Oh,
so he's supposed to be able to sling and six days.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Is that six days?
Whatever.
Tuesdays.
Yeah.
Wow.
So my guy is really a grad,
so I went to Dr. Andrews.
He's out there and I'm in Pensacola and he said,
no,
we need you back punching in two months.
So the day after surgery,
heart surgery,
he said making contact.
So two months.
I mean right after surgery I was doing two a days fucking full last rehab.
Really?
Yeah,
like crazy.
So I'm like,
these dudes is nuts.
This shoulder.
I had this done in Oh eight I didn't move for like three weeks.
What'd you have done with that one?
Anything Labor now you,
you hurting this and training.
Are you hurting it in fights?
Um,
a lot of people don't know about me.
They think I just throw my right hand a lot,
but I wasn't never really confident with my left hand because I had that left
leg room tear.
So it felt weird to throw hooks and it felt weird to use my jab a lot,
my shoulder fatigue a lot.
So I didn't tell a lot of people that.
So I just started bombing,
bombing like hell with my right hand.
It wasn't because I was just her writing in heavy.
So now that I had the surgery on this one,
I'm one of the stem cell bolt.
Shoulders rehabbed the crap out of it.
And also about this on the Rehab machine called an art wave.
You ever heard of it?
Like a Russian.
Stan is like nuts.
No.
What is it?
It's like a Russian stim machine that has the ability to make your muscles
contract 500 times a second at its highest setting.
So a lot of people use it.
A coach use it.
A lot of pro athletes use it.
The people that made it in Minnesota,
they don't give a lot of information because they don't want to answer.
That's real property stolen,
but they charge you like 12 to 14 grand for the machine.
Then they charge you five grand and show you how to use it.
Then if you really,
really want to know how to use it,
they charge you as another 500 I mean five grand.
So I was lucky enough,
I hope they ain't watching that shit.
I was lucky enough to get one from my homie,
Mark Clayton.
They used to play with the rams.
I just bought his from him.
And so what did,
what is it called again?
It's called an arp wave.
Art Wave.
Aarp arp.
ARP,
which stands for advanced program?
Yeah,
while dance recovery program.
So basically if you think about scar tissue,
soft tissue,
it has ability.
It's not like that stem that feels like the needle poke in,
but it's like intense stem that goes through.
It can break their fucking scar tissue or um,
go to soft tissue and basically increased blood flow,
range of motion.
So sprang ankles,
you know,
in one session.
That should be,
he'll real.
Yeah,
I've used it hundreds and hundreds the time.
I just didn't have the money to buy it until recently.
Wow.
They use it to since college.
And so now you put this on your shoulder and what will you put it on your
shoulder?
An ad like this posture.
So you hold this posture just position.
Right.
Um,
and then they also do a balance as first because if your back is fucked up,
you need and your balance is off,
then neurologically it's not going to actually sin.
Um,
the,
the current to the right spot.
So they,
maybe she'll Laura back and your shoes are fucked up,
so now your shoes are messed up.
So make it a lower back.
Her,
you know how to balance test,
right?
So they do that first adjust.
You make sure you all balanced out.
Then they find what they call a hotspot.
So he put at a neutral site,
the black pad,
which is like your lower back or something.
Then wherever you're feeling the pain,
if I'm feeling it right here,
the pain might not be covered from there.
So they might,
they searched around and who does she jump out?
So now this becomes a hotspot.
So now I take the other pat off and find a spot.
Then when they,
those who connect,
you feel like you're about to die.
Then they wrap you up and then they do seven minutes on reverse,
seven minutes on positive,
and then it's,
it's painful as shit.
But like I've done training calves has some severe injuries and nobody would
ever,
ever no real.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
So like,
so you saying that like if you have something that's bothering you,
a lot of times there's something is wrong somewhere else that's causing that to
be bothering you and this somehow or another finds that
you,
you balance,
you do a valid test first.
So say like a chiropractor comes in and he say,
Oh,
you hips off your legs longer.
He just,
you,
you have to be adjusted and balanced first.
Then they put the pads on it and you locate what?
They caught a hotspot.
So say my shoulder,
right.
For some reason I broke my wrist a long time ago,
so I can't do like that.
So it can push down on things.
So you see how I can't get my hand to bed.
Oh,
so if you get down to push up top,
I'm going to like this because my wrist is in the best.
Yeah.
So when I'm throwing a punch,
especially if I'm telling you it's a crazy as punch,
you can imagine that if I don't distribute the force properly,
they shits.
My form's gonna be sore.
Probably what's caused my shoulder pain.
Also being extended position and wrestling extended stretched out over time and
time.
It caused a shock.
Now just that one punch I hit Damien Maia with,
maybe that wasn't a punch.
They might've been the last straw that broke the camel's back.
But I think wearing in from all those different years just beat my showed up.
So you all said,
what's this guy doing here?
Foreign and after best kind of version.
I think I got kind of a good video.
Yeah.
Ran Range of emotion wise is is is actually deceiving because sometimes you'll
fucking get zapped on this deal and you couldn't bring your arm up at all and
then all of a sudden now you're like,
oh shit I'm hill.
But you're not really heal.
You got to continue to do the protocol,
continued to do the treatment and work on range of motion.
If you can do it one time you feel great.
Go out there and started shooting threes.
You're shit got me fucked up.
Yeah.
So so in the Damien Maia fight you hurt your shoulder like with one of the first
punches you through,
right guys?
I was,
I knew it happened because I knew it.
I knew it's what they call sub plex or dislocate or whatever.
So I do,
I saw an opening had already launched his eye up and my arms trying to fuck
that.
The side of his face up.
So I saw as I'm left eyeball already,
almost close.
So I say I finished had to go ham on bow,
I'll do the punch and I felt my shoulders go down and I'm like,
Oh shit.
So then I was like,
I can't lose a fight again at to do take my bill.
So at this point I said,
I'm going to throw straight punches and reaction and I see my power punch,
I'm a throw it.
So a couple times I forgot and I threw it and Kinda went out again and he took
some shots and I lift him up and they kind of went out again.
So three or four times in a fight,
I can feel it.
You just go like go like a whole like five or six light bulbs,
just crushing me,
your shoulder,
you kind of feeling going.
But I had that pain before and I'm,
and I'm,
I mean it sounds stupid.
I'm blessed that I tore this one because I knew what it felt like.
And I know that the only pain that I'm in the fields when I extend,
when I tried to go that direction or any overhead,
right.
That shit was going to be a rap.
So when I stayed here I just do straight punches and there's a couple of times I
blitz it forward and I wanted to punch and I didn't punch because I didn't feel
confident when my hand.
Hmm.
So you,
you kind of,
you knew something was wrong.
They just didn't know exactly what it was.
I knew,
I knew it's sub plex,
so I knew a dislocated for sure whether the ligament was torn,
not,
I was praying that it wasn't,
cause you can actually do that,
slip it out without a tiering.
But most times when you do that as a result of these muscles fatigue and you
punch into hard making contact with your target and then your whole muscle,
you just go,
you just kinda feel like the best way I can explain it,
everything's just kind of fell down.
So you tried to rehab it for a while,
tried to,
what did you try to do?
May I did,
I did the arb treatment.
Um,
I did regular physical therapy.
I mean you got an MRI,
Mri.
I got two Mris.
I had one doctor telling me that,
you know,
I didn't have to do it.
I could one doctor can care less.
Um,
and then finally I went to Dr. Andrews and he was like,
you know what,
how long do you plan on fighting for?
And a,
and I hate when people ask me this because I'm fine.
I'm like,
Shit until I get tired of fighting.
And he was like,
well,
if you think you're going to be done fighting then don't get it done.
But if you want to have a career and you want to be able to constantly punch,
he said,
I watch your video.
He said,
you make your money with your right hand.
if you want to go out there and punch and be confident,
let me go in there and then be cleaned it out.
Let me anchor down.
Um,
we will shoot some stem cells and PRP in there on the way out of the surgery.
we'd be aggressive and make sure you get that range of motion and um,
you'll be back in there punching.
So I decided that my ass for four times for world title fights in a year,
if anybody deserved to touch up something they heard in the fight,
just me.
So,
uh,
I decided to go with it.
I'm,
I was so close man.
Even all the way up until the day of surgery,
I was like,
man,
I don't want to fucking do this.
I don't want to do this and I just don't want to be doing surgery now.
We you still training?
We're still throwing punches.
Yeah,
I was trying to do.
And what did it feel like when you're throwing punches?
Um,
I mean that's the reason why I got it.
I mean uppercuts straight punches along that if I throw a straight punch and I
didn't turn my body over and I was just on punching,
she ever,
the uppercut didn't hurt.
Uh,
I was shadowboxing hidden paths hitting the bag.
If I throw it overhand right.
It was not feeling,
it was not going to happen.
So shoulders is such a weird joint,
you know,
there's so much motion.
Even now,
like you're doing a rehab now,
like part of my protocols with dumbbells,
I can,
I can slay a,
but if I come out here,
I mean you can just see if you see the way my body's starting to get alarmed,
I don't feel comfortable yet.
But you're only,
how many days out of surgery?
Two weeks.
Two weeks is nothing amazing that you can move.
I'll be back.
I'll be back training a couple of months.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well what?
This art machine and then with stem cells and PRP,
it's like the world's a different place now for engine had this shit in 2008 so
I'd tell you,
and I rehabbed myself.
I took,
so our rehab book,
I had all these protocols from the sports medicine people that gave me and I put
my own shit together and I made my own workout and I did it religiously,
twice a day.
But it's not the same as somebody stretching you every single degrees,
every direction,
every plane watching your growth and actually being a specialist.
I was just doing shit cause I didn't want my shoulder messed up and I just
started fighting.
Like when I first started I was a wrestling coach for Tlo,
Alvarez.
Either words,
Dean Thomas.
I wasn't really a fight or Friday I had a couple of amateur fights,
but I didn't know if I wanted to do this shit or not.
Then I had to have a shoulder surgeon.
I'm like,
damn man,
I don't know how the hell I'm gonna pay for this.
So a guy named Wade Rome,
he was American top team guy.
I didn't know what the fucking American top team was.
He brought the satellite school,
the University of Missouri where I was coaching at.
He came into the gym and he wanted to pay for our weight room,
a wrestling team.
And I'm like,
well shit,
let me go in there and train to his gym.
And I wasn't trained his jam and I worked for him for time so I can get
insurance so I can get the shoulder surgery and um,
shit.
After that I said,
let me get this fight and take a shower.
I wasn't even,
I was,
I didn't,
I was just doing it just to see what it was like.
But that's crazy.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
When you think about how successful you've been at it,
and I had a lot of chances to quit too.
Broke in debt,
50 grand in debt.
And I'm like,
I told my coach,
I said,
I can't do this shit.
And when I said I'm a fulltime coach,
um,
I'm going negative day 15 out of 30 days,
man,
I can't even afford the,
that's when gas,
remember if gas first hit,
I was getting 99 thing gas and all of a sudden wants to three bucks at the
broker's point of my life.
I was like hell with that.
So I did that.
And he said,
you know what?
You got a future in this man.
He said,
take out a student loan.
I was in graduate school.
He said,
take out a student loan.
So I took out a student loan and graduate school to fund my MMA training.
Wow.
And I didn't even finish graduate school.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Isn't it all worked out the way it did.
It worked out.
I would complain about it Dan and tried to pay me 50 grand,
less known being 50 grand in debt.
You know,
it's like tables have turn quite a bit.
Yeah,
it's fascinating isn't it?
When you look back,
if you look back 10 years ago,
10 years ago,
God,
I can't believe I've been fighting for,
what is it,
1213 years now?
2005 was my first fight.
Wow.
Nuts.
Now your world champ.
So with this uh,
rehabilitation,
they said there they'd like you to throw punches inside of two months.
Yeah.
And then when would you be able to like fully resume training?
They think three of us.
They think three months.
I mean granted with this surgery you can hear someone say four months,
you can hit six months.
Some people take a full year.
It depends on who the surgeon is,
how aggressively they push you for.
It depends on why you need to get back.
I got a belt to defend and I got money to make and I got people asking me,
so I got to get back.
So with that said,
I'm going,
I called the UFC,
I'm like,
this is bullshit.
I'm you're world champion.
I need one.
Am I going to do with three days a week and I'm not a senior citizen.
I need physical therapy approved for five days a week.
I need this game ready ice machine.
I need to do PRP in six weeks.
They should want me to get back.
And you know,
um,
they,
they listened to me and say,
you know what?
He's right.
You know,
give them whatever you want to give him so he can get back and get her and
fighting because I was fighting extremely often for them.
Now you,
you're living in St Louis?
Yeah,
I live,
I've got a house in Saint Louis.
I'm out here every week though.
I'm doing Fox TMZ.
I didn't know you were doing that many different TV things.
So what are you doing on Fox?
I do.
I'm doing UFC tonight.
DC's out and trying to count.
So anytime DC,
Brisbane or whatever,
I'm usually got,
it fills in where you'll see it tonight and you have to come out here and do
that every week.
Wow.
They don't watch him say,
Hey bids me you,
you are in DC.
Don't watch.
I said I'm a snag.
Get Damn job.
I'm be a permanent out here.
Cause I had a good show yesterday.
I didn't want to watch out.
Do you like doing that?
I loved doing it.
I love getting out of the box.
That's why,
you know,
I know he probably gonna get it until later.
That's why I did stand up comedy the other day.
I did stand up comedy.
I heard about the Adam Hunter had you up at the Dharma and wants to diamond bar
because I feel like acting is what I'm going to do after I get in a fight and,
and if you can be okay with being embarrassed,
not being uncomfortable and really not giving a fuck,
then you can become a great actor if you have the gift and you're willing to put
in the work.
So I've always put in the work.
I'm not worried about that.
But if I've got to cry,
I got to be a college douche bag.
I it to be something that I'm not used to being.
I can be a tough guy all day.
I can be a secret agent,
you know?
I mean,
you're gonna film this,
you know,
we can watch a film and Mimic it,
for ice and mimic Friday.
You cannot tell me I wasn't smoky,
I was sounds just like Chris Ducker.
Like I was really in the fucking movie,
but he didn't have anybody to look at.
He had a fucking script and he had to bring that to life.
And you know,
we really critical and actors and I just don't want to be the weakest link,
everyone in the film.
So.
So that's what you want to do when you're done with all that?
For sure.
It that always been an aspiration or is it something you saw as like a way to do
it after it's over a lot of stuff,
you know,
I don't really even like fighting to real honest.
Yeah,
I'm just good at it.
What don't you like about it?
I don't like the politics behind it.
I don't like to,
a martial art aspects has been taken away from it.
I don't like to um,
disrespect to the sport.
Um,
guys that are,
you're not,
not really training hard.
Um,
it don't look the part I think professional athletes you look a certain way.
I really just don't like the youth.
This generation of fighters that watching move on TV on youtube and they go in,
they tried to do it.
They don't want to drill repetitions,
lead.
I don't want to actually put in the work.
Um,
why does that affect you though?
It affects me because our sport is also the fans and the fans actually culture
who gets to fight and if a guy's going to talk enough shit and so I went and
flight suits then this day and age that's good enough for a title shot and I
think it's disrespectful to everybody that came before that.
Remember that you had to go 10 to know.
Then you get the fucking call from the UFC,
give kind of one RM,
low ball fun in the UFC and a 500 record he's going to be in the UFC.
And I just,
it's,
it's ways that the sport is taken a love out of it.
But I just find a way in dominated my opponents,
taking all the tools away from them.
You know,
Dean Tom and shout out to them and Duke Roufus are fucking masterminds.
So I take pride in that,
take pride and go in and they're not getting hit dominated,
knocking people out,
whatever I got.
When you say you don't like fighting,
you'd like all those things you don't like to what other people are doing?
I love training.
I don't like what I don't like to,
we'll split the spores become,
so this is an interesting thing to talk about because a lot of people have
different points of view on that.
And one hand,
a lot of people like the traditional martial arts approach of respect for your
opponent and just fighting to the best of your abilities and letting the chips
fall where they may.
Whereas other people say,
well,
listen,
to get people to show up,
to get asses in seats,
to get paper view bys,
there's gotta be some drama and some entertainment value to it.
And that's where someone like Connor comes into Connor's the only one has done
it though.
Yeah.
Well Rhonda a little bit.
Rhonda did it a little bit is done at the best.
And when he actually puts in the work,
right,
he had a son before he has Sunday deal,
but he didn't,
he,
he his mouth,
his mouth was louder and he's actually probably the best at it.
He's,
he's probably,
he's better than Conor.
Edit condoms.
Very close.
But Connor actually delivers on more than more of what he said he's going to do
it in shell dead.
I would agree.
So if you got to think of anybody who's brought both worlds together best,
I would have to say Connor,
he knocks a lot of guys out.
Try to call the round.
He's only lost a few fights total.
And even those fights,
it was RiskMatch war fighting the guy switched opponent this notice different
weight class.
Um,
you know,
he second those risks and rewards that if you lose,
it's not really that big of a deal.
You know,
nobody's gonna Really,
oh my God.
Dropping down to the bottom of the pack.
But these other guys that haven't done it don't have the skills,
ain't putting in the work.
I mean,
they can kind of really just,
we see the trend,
right?
There is a trend right now at least though,
incredibly disrespectful,
very rude.
And you know,
you saw what happened with Colby Covington and you know,
at least be over doing Marangu you know what I mean?
You pressing charges.
I mean,
that is a queef well,
this [inaudible] there's a lot of attention being placed on him though.
I mean,
you,
you see,
it's nicely effective.
Let me see how much attention is being placed.
It is effective in the moment,
right?
I mean,
don't want to go back to this stuff.
It's effective in a moment.
I'm gonna tell you why.
Because sometimes there's some talking about sports is like,
you know,
nothing going on.
It was like,
fuck with this guy was talking,
shit,
let me listen to him.
Right.
And right there at that point Kinda was around.
Rhonda wasn't around.
I wasn't around who is UFC really projected as a star,
says North Korea had a few bumps,
Pace.
Van Zandt had a few bumps.
They tried to push up in Ghana,
but what started did they have?
So if you got this person that's willing to go crazy,
even though we know it's WWE,
the person's really not getting slammed.
We want to live in that moment anyway.
We want to go for the villain.
Who has he really beat behind Damien Maia?
What was,
what was the other top 15 victory?
Well,
the Damien Meyer was a big one,
but that was a big one.
But he was,
but he was unmotivated and he was a guy that already had his title shots and you
know,
he's getting up there in age.
What is really his motivation?
I wrote the book on how to beat Damien Maia and he didn't even read the book.
He just skim through it because no part of the book said,
let the Jujitsu guy fuck you up and bloody your face.
Colby competent did that by himself.
I didn't do that,
you know,
even with my right arm being messed up.
So,
um,
yeah,
he just,
I'm just looking like how many followers,
just
like he didn't have a big following before that that was his biggest fight.
That was the big,
the big coming.
I don't want to discredit him.
They minimize the,
Gee,
you know,
I don't want to discredit Colby,
but you know,
for you,
for,
for me,
have some people in your resume have some,
you know,
I didn't be Derrick Terex,
Hafeni Paul Daley,
Jordan,
me,
and this is before I even got into UFC.
My first fight was Jay Heran who had only been stopped by George Saint Pierre
lost one fight to be in action that was close and had won every fight after
that.
So I never had an easy fight.
All my guys was either former champions or former contenders are former,
you know,
people that were interim champions.
And when you got a list like that and you should don't get the respect Koscheck
condit when he Robbie Lawler,
you don't get the respect from who
caught him.
Oh my God.
Can care less about
the respect.
You definitely get respect.
Watch this.
When you think of Robbie Lawler,
Carlos Condit,
right?
Right.
They're in a different category as it were to you that I'm the champion.
I beat both of those guys.
What do you mean by a different category?
I see them in a category then this might just be me.
I see them is in the category is if you're talking about guys are going to enter
the hall of fame,
right?
And you think about all Josh costs checking,
um,
oh,
Carlos condit and Robbie Lawler and you know this guy and Anderson Silva,
all those different guys.
But it's funny that I've defeated these guys,
man.
You're crazy.
You're talking crazy.
I don't think so.
Yeah,
no,
you definitely
talking crazy.
You're the champ champ.
You,
you're acting like people don't respect you as the champ.
They respect.
They were sneaky.
People think like that.
Carlos condit gets more respect or Robbie Lawler gets more.
That's crazy.
Carlos condit gets more respect me.
Robbie Lawler gets more respect to me.
But from who though?
Sure.
Even guys,
even guys that I defeated,
like you know,
um,
Stephen Thompson tea shops and they'll get more respect to me.
I'm not gonna say that,
but people are willing to be like,
oh my God.
You know,
tell them Dana said,
tell them to get in the cage with Tyrone Woodley.
He didn't say,
hey tire and tell them to get in case with Stephen Thompson on a seven fight win
streak,
knocking everybody fuck out with a really super weird style that took me months
in a fortune,
bringing all these fucking crazy taekwondo,
Raymond Daniels,
all these,
the best of the best to train him to beat him,
right?
Like nobody gave me that pass.
She don't know why you concentrate on that.
I know that seems,
but you are because you're talking about it.
I'm not concentrating on when he has these nutty thoughts.
I'm telling you,
this is all nonsense.
This is a wasted,
wasted energy.
You think when you think about and that it doesn't matter to me because my path
is pretty clear what I want to do.
I want to do the best.
I want to rent.
I want to be the best.
Well,
Twitter defended undisputed UFC welterweight champion in 2007 when that was the
shit.
Now Shit,
what is in the middle of why kind of middle of last quarter and they fight and
supervise that are bigger than a world title fight because I didn't make no,
I know you as much.
You don't know you as much yet and whether whatever.
Look,
Connor is a weird enigma and whatever reason why that got caught fire the way he
did.
It's a weird combination of personality,
results,
skill.
It's a lot.
And Ireland,
Ireland is a big factor.
I mean if Conner was from Nebraska,
I guarantee you
it's not just a big fight country.
The loyalty and the love that those people have for the people that fight from
Ireland.
There's not no,
there's nothing like that.
It's,
it's a,
it's a weird anomaly.
So he's just this weird aberration and he gives people almost like false hope of
what's possible because I don't know if it's possible with a lot of people just,
it just,
it's lightening in a bottle for whatever reason.
It worked with him,
but he started himself and what happened?
Her company jumper cables.
Yeah.
You'll see.
Put the machine behind them.
Right.
They definitely put them on.
It made sense machine behind him.
There was giant hordes of people flying in from Ireland.
I remember one of some of his earlier fights I was like,
and I was commenting on and I was saying this is a guy who was on the undercard
and they're acting like this is the main event of a paper view.
They flown from Ireland.
The audience is filled with thousands of people that flew from Ireland deciding
to bring my age and does.
Even back then.
It was insane when he fell back
then,
you know,
it was funny,
somebody when I was striking coach was like,
Conor Mcgregor's is huge star and da Da da Da.
I'm like,
that's when he had first gotten to UFC and I'm like,
I don't even know who the fuck is cute is.
He would tell he was trying to convince me,
no,
he's a superstar.
He's Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And in every time I get to share,
as I said,
you,
you were right.
He wasn't dead,
but he's more of a gay ended up being a superstar and he loves to get their
credit because at that moment I think I was getting ready to fight dung and Kim
and he kept on with this Conor McGregor.
So I said,
let me look,
this is my friend.
Let me look them up because you obviously got a boner for this dude.
And I looked him up.
I'm like,
all right,
he's good.
I get it,
but let me see him,
be it a couple of people and then if he can be dust Emporio,
then I'm going to give him his props.
Knocking doctor.
It's important.
It doesn't pray.
I,
all right,
well he's 100% legit.
He's legit.
It's what else is going on that's so weird.
It's,
he's not just legit.
He's also this unbelievable personality that people were drawn to him.
That's no one can manufacture that.
So like he's,
he's rehearsed it.
He's practiced that.
He's looked in the mirror,
he has natural wit.
He's,
he's willing to go risky.
And say some below to build shit.
And he does his research.
He don't come to a press conference,
just you know,
smoking.
You'd like to front row of a comedy show,
he looking into some deep shit.
And when you get there,
you kind of stumble.
So you right,
he has that.
He also has a fight style.
He also has so happened to do 80% of shit he says going to do.
So now he's the fucking Messiah.
But you can't say that the UFC has not gotten behind you or people don't give
you the respect that you deserve.
That's why you're not in the same level as you said.
You said that it,
him and Connor are super fights.
I'm saying that he has gotten it and I was saying that he has gotten it and he
has lived up to what he said he's going to do.
And then on top of that,
you gotta you gotta be able to fight.
He can fight and he has been able to talk.
So now,
not only can he generate the pay per view,
buys and get people interested,
he's actually gonna deliver a knockout.
Again,
Josie auto stop as it gets Eddie Alvarez and the crazy,
you know,
back to back fights with,
with Nate Diaz.
Don't you think that you're in an unusual situation?
First of all,
because you win the title by spectacular first round knockout against Robbie
Lawler.
Unbelievable knockout.
But then you have the most awkward and difficult God to defend your title
against Wonderboy.
Thompson is a very unusual opponent and it's hard to look good against them and
that'll all the people that fought him,
you're the only guy that put him in danger.
Not once,
but twice.
And the way you fought him.
I've defended the way you fought him many times.
Cause I say,
look,
if you look at tactically,
if you look at technique and you look at the,
the,
the art of fighting,
that's the way to find them.
If you're a guy like Tyron Woodley,
a powerful punch,
it was a great wrestler.
Who's got one real one punch,
knockout ability.
You're not going to open yourself up to Wonderboy.
Going to rush him either.
Exactly.
Don't get picked apart.
You're not going to fight him the way he wants to fight would you did as you
laid back a lot and people booed a lot because of that.
But when you connected,
you are the one that heard him in those two fights.
He was the one that
was in big trouble in both of those fights.
Not You.
Him with his fire was,
it was,
it was not for me.
I'm never,
um,
you know,
I got the same thing in the Maya fight,
but at the end of the day and someone's attempted to take you down multiple
times,
over 20 times.
It's very hard to get in any type of exchange.
Every time you swing,
they want to go on and eat three shots.
Maya fight was tough too,
but you got to go back and look at like Anderson Silva's dark days.
There was a dark days when Anderson Silva fought Damien Maia where nobody wants
to have anything to do with them after that.
Fine.
Yeah.
And Anderson Silva fought.
Um,
when he fought there,
there's several fights where um,
he had just boring results and people weren't interested in him finding anymore.
One spectacular knockout and everybody's
got it all over again.
And then one spectacular knock out to get the belt and then everybody slowly
forget about it moments later.
Cause at the time Stephen Thompson said,
Nah,
we're the fight Robbie and I think he's going to win anyway and Da da Da.
And then he think I'm supposed to be just so graciously like God that's fighting
honor and Nah,
you wanted to fight Robbie,
right?
You say rob,
who's going to win?
You say you personally prefer to write fight Robbie Cause I've been waiting
around even though that wasn't the case.
So you said this up.
So don't think that I'm just going to give you my spotlight and say hey,
you know what the others do this.
No.
If I'm seeing the table being set,
I know there's Nate disease out there.
Nick Diaz is out there.
George Saint Pierre is Michael Business guys that have that name,
they have that status that I'm trying to get to.
Those are the guys I want to fight.
I want to knock those guys now because now I can continue to enjoy myself up
fighting him.
Well,
he's trying to get the same thing I'm trying to get,
why the hell am I going to pull you up with me?
Right.
If that's the fight.
They wanted me to fight him.
One of one.
They never offered me the fight.
He said something.
Then I think the UFC thought I wouldn't take the fight is the first time they
offered me the fight accepted it.
So when all these people are like,
oh my God,
you don't want to fight trying to pick his fights,
he's just got the belt.
I'm like,
Ooh man,
I'm talking about,
it's too many people saying things that you're responding to that are,
that are irrelevant I think is the,
the people that that are in the organization.
I got to,
you know,
you're dealing with people that I don't deal with them in that regard,
but as far as like people that are analysts and experts as far as like the
social media,
like I really don't read social media.
I post because I want to post and I leave it alone.
So that's why I say that.
I'm not saying without saying who it is.
I'm not saying that the fans are making me feel some type of way cause my,
my path is clear.
I want to be the greatest welterweight of all time.
Right?
Whatever it takes.
When,
when I get an opportunity,
I'm trying to knock you out.
Okay.
At all times.
Stephen Thompson is different types of fights as you said before.
Look what happened with Robert Whitaker,
rushed in and look what happened when this guy approached him.
Those guys,
that's,
people forget if you get all this shit and it also realize how tough it is to
take him down and gets the case.
Remember how fast he pops up.
So why did I get myself 31 foot that if I want to double check am I got the
whole place to stretch across some blast tomorrow he don't have one punch Carol
power.
So if my back is against the octagon and when I go for a shot,
I got the whole entire actually going to take them now versus pressing them
gopher to take down him in the cage or both defending my shot.
Then Dan him trying to,
you know,
do some razzle dazzle kick.
So I have no issue with the way I fought him.
Um,
or Damien Maia,
I don't think there's another way to fight them unless
I did.
He didn't,
he didn't take Maya series.
He didn't train the way.
He didn't bring in the top Jiu Jitsu guys like with easy to spark kickbox and
look good and never have to take a shot.
The way I train,
I put myself in positions.
I know I'm never going to be in.
You never going to take me down.
You never go have my bag.
I'm never going to be mounted.
But I'm training that ship anyway.
Just in case I slipped on a banana peel,
I get clipped with a punch.
So George Jr's,
Mazda Dow,
just from the way I watched him fight,
he was surprised.
Even the stuff that Stephen Thompson hit me with,
it never surprised me.
I get hit with it.
He landed some good shots.
He's really quick.
I mean I'm fast and explosive,
but he's quick.
Those punches get to you fast.
He's long and we started bouncing.
You don't even know what the hell are you going to do and this kind of like what
are you about to do?
When do you about to do?
You can watch his performance until he didn't do the proper work.
Same thing with Damien Maia.
He trained with Colby and like tried to take me down.
I'm gonna stop the shot and just knock you out.
That's not how it works.
You've got to bring in guys and know his half guard,
how he hooks her ankle,
Holly suites,
how he switched from one side to the other.
What happens when he grabbed him around your waist?
If you give him his back,
this is how you can lock up.
I trained with guys that trained with him and the guys would have better than
Damien my on the mat that way when I got out there had he taking me down,
I would've been prepared to escape,
get away,
get back to my feet.
Do you think that having a chip on your shoulder in some way helps you like all
these people that doubt you in some way?
You have to prove yourself.
I just know that I'm the best.
Like you know,
me and dean was training one day and I stopped practicing.
I just,
I had a brain fart and I started thinking about George Saint Pierre and I
started thinking about all those skills and I start thinking about Robbie and
all the time,
well two and I said,
I'm the fucking best in the world.
Nobody's fastened to me.
Nobody stronger than me.
Nobody works as hard as I do.
Nobody has all the skills to striking the wrestling.
Did you just who the defense,
the timing,
the explosion,
the toughness.
I've been in wars,
I've been in close fights,
I've been in fights.
One knock people out.
I've been in it all.
So when I decided that I'm the best,
I saw,
I carry myself as if I was already the champion.
And that's why I had champ camp before I even had the belt.
And which was,
when was this around?
Like which fight?
Oh,
I'm rights Shit Robbie.
Right before,
right before Robin.
Yeah.
I was supposed to not champ camp.
Actually we're supposed to start with um,
when Johnny,
but Johnny has some complications that make it to the scale.
So they told me I was fighting Robbie.
Yeah,
I remember talking to you backstage one day,
uh,
one of the wins and you were frustrated and you were like,
when the fuck am I getting my title shot?
Yeah.
Well that,
you know,
that this is the thing,
we know the game changes and sometimes they want to see fights play out before
they make a call.
They never want to be an alliance and you are definitely getting a title shot.
They've done it a couple of times and we've seen what happened.
Right.
And they pulled out of it.
So I fought Kelvin gasoline and Kelvin gasoline was supposed to be this
conditioning freak and he ms way by 10 pounds in,
you know,
for me,
I don't play this shit.
Don't act like you were so sick.
No,
you didn't make weight.
And what happens when you don't make weight?
You actually didn't have to go through in suck your body all the way down to
scratch.
Wait like I did.
So you should actually look better.
So I don't want to be like,
oh,
he was sick and that's why,
you know,
he had a chance.
He just has never going to beat me.
I fought him.
He was the one that was huffing and puffing.
He couldn't hit me.
He couldn't land any significant punch.
Islanded and after that fight,
you know,
um,
it was some scrutiny on the fight.
I'm like,
okay,
you made it grapple with him so he can try and take my back and do a redneck
truck like did everybody else?
You want me to exchange with him and let him get into the fight when I know I'm
fast.
I know I'm sharper.
He can't hit me.
I got better defense the whole time he's pushing me against the case.
I heard score said,
no,
don't go there.
Don't go there.
It was terrified that the Kaushik thing was going to happen to him,
so he backed up every time he pushed me into the octagon.
Why wouldn't I play on that?
You know what I mean?
So when people look at that,
he was saying that he was going to get a title shot.
I wonder if you remember that.
They said if Kelvin Gasmon would be Tyree,
he going to get a tighter shot.
You run.
I remember people saying that.
They were saying I,
but they weren't saying.
They didn't say that at NRB.
Dana White said,
if Kelvin Gasland bees,
Tyron,
he's getting a title shot.
Remember he had already been coached,
selected for the coach.
He got the coach's job off the loss after missing weight by 10 pounds.
And then they told me he would never fight it.
One 85 again if I took the fight.
I mean one 70 again if I took the fight.
So he lost me.
Ms. Wade still got to Tufts coaching job and on top of that he was going to get
a tighter shot had he beaten me.
But why do you,
so you again,
it comes to this chip on your shoulder thing.
You feel like everybody's against,
you know,
you do a little,
I don't want,
do you want me to though?
No,
you do.
This is what you're saying.
It's the things that you're saying
send.
I'm just saying that I know.
I know the,
I know the deck of cards I got and a lot of play.
These technical,
what do you think the deck of cards is?
The deck of cards is going to come a moment where I'm a superstar and when I get
to that moment,
I have more leverage at this time.
I'm not at the point where kind McGregor's at,
so I got,
if I got to fight the number one contender and I can't vouch Altify to George
Saint Pierre or Bisbing or a con or a native at this moment,
I'm going to keep whooping ass until I get to the,
well after Georges beaten.
Right now.
George is in an amazing position.
Right.
George Beats Bisbing if he wanted it and he dropped the title.
But if you wanted to come back and fight you for uh,
the welterweight title,
that's a legitimate super fight right there.
I mean that makes a lot of sense.
Just coming off of his big fight.
You don't think he does?
Look,
did you tell me,
you think judge [inaudible] your faith
George had George.
Yeah,
the,
she has to fight me before business.
He chose if I business well maybe you felt like that was a better fight for him
to come back with.
It was a definitely a better fight cause he would have came back and gets me
looking like that.
George would have been right back in retirement.
He did not look great business and didn't all look great.
Um,
one thing that helped George Nfi his experience,
he loosened up.
He was a little uptight.
You know,
he hadn't been an octagon.
We're four years almost a little over two or three.
Right.
It's more than that was it for,
it was almost four.
It wasn't quite far.
It's almost for her.
Cause I fall November,
I found November UFC,
there was a 25th anniversary.
I think it was like fuck,
because fall Kasha here in the cart.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's a long ass time for him to not fight that long chroma.
She's trained Yo ass end in a fight.
You don't have a train of camp focus on a person.
It's tough.
So when he came back,
I saw the experience kit.
Can he relax a little bit?
That's when he faked it.
Lending a left hook.
Heady.
Not relaxed.
I mean,
you know,
who knows would've happened.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It was,
uh,
it was interesting because Bisping was tight and I expected,
I expected him to be looser.
Big Bisbing doesn't have the,
the,
I mean he's not guys out,
but he's not a guy that,
you know,
you're taken over like a rumble way or in cotton or myself or someone shot
Stephens,
Jeremy Stevens,
somebody who's going to touch you in this overweight.
So with that said,
he's a,
he's a person that's going to be volume.
He's gonna be in your face.
Great conditioning.
He's very durable.
And George had to make that adjustment.
He said,
all right,
and it'd be an athlete on this guy.
Then we fake him out and let me get them thinking about the shot.
I took him down twice.
Let me get them thinking about it.
Level change come up,
left foot,
very smart move.
And that's something that the experience of being a champion,
a lot of them do.
Well,
there was some talk about him fighting Conor,
but I didn't hear any of that from the official people.
And him fighting Conor at 170 pounds would've been fascinating in terms of like,
it's a terrible matchup for Connor.
Yeah.
You know,
in terms of like just physicality and once again,
risk and reward.
What happens when you see the greatest welterweight of all time?
People going to torture him about it.
Yeah.
But Canada's once that was another fight right now,
like this is not a good time,
especially in his division.
There's so much talent right now.
He want to see.
He'll be right now.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I want.
I mean Tony's,
uh,
if,
if I was Connor,
which I'm not,
um,
if I had to pick the fight,
they both are going to be,
I mean he'll be,
might be a bigger draw.
Cause he got huge,
huge,
147 million people in Russia might be a bigger draw,
but they both are very annoying fights,
very dangerous fights.
Dangerous Tony Ferguson,
you know,
it don't take much for him to find a way to get around your neck and choke.
And he's always get tired.
He doesn't get tired.
He looks like he's losing fights and he don't care.
It's striking is very awkward.
Um,
he can really do what they did is did to Conor and Nate Diaz baffled.
I'm like,
damn,
I hit you with everything.
You still around then Kinda were for the damn shot.
The same thing's gonna happen if do that to Tony.
Tony's going to submit him.
Here's my prediction,
my prediction,
Congress and fight for a while.
He watched those two things to trip him.
They strip Connor,
he comes by me,
Habib and Tony Fight for the world title for you.
One of
those guys were in the car is right now,
but for you my dream,
what's your dream?
You know what my dream was to really,
I wanted to,
I wanted to find yours and as possible.
I feel like if I fall George,
I can legitimately say I'm the best welterweight of all time.
If I beat him,
it's still possible.
George hasn't retired.
They said anything about you.
He asked one time on like Fox Q and a or he was gonna like so tired and if he
fought,
what would be your game plan?
You know if you fought us but it got exed out because they didn't want to get
all the fans pumped up that we were fighting.
Why wouldn't they?
Do you think there
plotting against you?
I was hearing it.
Seeing your face,
Joe.
He is that going to do I am too bright.
You want me to be like other people who are against me?
Listen,
I want you to just be focused.
You want me to be real?
Yeah,
show me real sure.
Do I think that the people want to see me lose?
No,
I don't think they want to see me a little.
So I think that sometimes I'm a pain in the ass.
Yeah,
I am.
But in business,
at one point in any business,
there's not the person that's doing the business now what they best interest.
So if I'm an athlete and I'm looking out for my best interest and I'm trying to
put myself in a position where you know,
I can fight,
become a legend and become a hall of Famer,
I should do that.
If I want to be paid appropriately,
And our sport,
because of the way the UFC started,
we the damn UFC.
You do what we say and that's it.
No questions.
You fight who we want to fight,
you get paid.
We want to get paid.
And that's it.
And then what happened?
The specialist,
the one trick ponies stop.
Then collegian athletes are getting in their college wrestlers.
No,
Kenny Florian is the guy.
Damn.
I'm almost thinking about being a doctor at one point.
So now I got an intelligent people coming into the sport.
They just so happened to be businessmen,
entrepreneurs.
So now I'm looking at market value.
I'm seeing what these motherfuckers are making and guess what?
I should be making this if they're making that,
if I'm in a champion in this person's doing this,
I should do that.
No one would.
Everybody's making knowing all the numbers.
I want to be at least fair.
I don't ask for no crazy.
I'll ask no 15 million and all this other stuff.
So if me doing that makes me come difficult,
then I guess I'm just a little bit difficult.
Okay,
well let me,
let me look at it from their perspective,
what they look at in terms of what a,
an athlete is worth.
It's like how much are they bringing in?
Like what kind of pay per view buys?
Are you getting?
How much?
This is what I was bringing in when the first off fighting.
Well,
he wasn't making nearly as much money
back then,
but how much was he?
Everybody has to start the second way.
You can't,
you can't throw you out and say,
okay,
if I wonder boy,
um,
UFC blah blah,
blah.
And if you don't do five,
oh well you did 300 bucks,
$300,000 you're not a draw.
Okay.
How was I promoted as a champion?
How was,
okay,
this is a long circuitous sort of a conversation if we continue along this way,
but what I'm trying to say is
there's a way where it's like a circular,
it's sort of a thing you gonna to keep circling back around to it.
What I think is there's a way for if,
if you want to make a big super fight,
like if George Saint Pierre really wanted to make a big super fight in the UFC,
wanted to make a big superstar at a you,
that's the fight because one of two things happens.
Either he beats you and he's even bigger than ever,
or you beat him and you become bigger than ever.
Let's do it.
That's what I'm saying.
You know the fight.
That makes sense,
but that's,
that's,
that makes sense.
No one's trying to stop that from happening.
What when the UFC is not willing to pay a certain amount of money,
it's because they don't think they're going to get a certain amount of money.
It's not because they're trying to avoid getting paid.
If they thought that you could be some enormous superstar and they could make
Conor McGregor type money from you,
there's not,
they would never say,
yeah,
we don't want to do that cause we don't want to give Tyron power.
They don't think like that.
They think like they're numbers people.
They're trying to make pay per view buys and if you only sold 300,000 paper view
bys because the Wonderboy fight,
there's not much they can do about that.
I mean it's not whether or not you were promoted a certain way as a fighter is
like that fight for someone like me is fascinating.
But for the average fucking Johnny lunchbox,
I want to see blood cut type person.
That's not what the pay per views a Bob pack do.
Paid reviews a Bob before the fight takes place.
Right.
But they knew the style.
They knew the style,
they knew the matchup and especially the second year
it was,
it was the fight of the night on the biggest card of UFC history.
You'll see two oh five in Madison Square Garden.
According to them it was a best fight of the entire card.
So if that was the best fight and it was fine
cause he had got the award,
a fight of the night.
Yeah.
That's just so you can get a bonus though,
right?
I mean when you look at the fights in terms of like you could have a card where
there's a lot of fights that aren't entirely significant and that would be the
fight of the night.
I don't think there's anything wrong with that fight.
I've told you before,
I liked that fight.
Well as a UFC,
the people that are cash any checks if they deem,
cause they didn't want to make decisions.
Right.
Dana and whoever,
if they say that this fight was a fight of the night,
which means you get more money,
you get more money,
come back a couple more bucks.
But think about this,
how different was the sacrifice?
It was really kind of the same fight,
pretty much the same.
So how was that fight fight at night?
It didn't have very exact fucking fight.
A few months later is a boring fight.
Get it.
What happened there for said it's boring.
If you said it's born the worst,
who says born?
If Dana says born,
the world's going to say it's boring.
So,
well,
I never said it was better.
I'm just saying.
I'd say if you look at the result after the fact,
people might say that if you knew what happened during the fight and you might
say,
well,
it's boring to watch again,
but watching it live was not boring at all because the consequences are so
grave.
It's one of the things that I pointed out,
like if Wonderboy fucks up,
he's going to sleep.
If you fuck up,
you're going to get kicked in the head too.
Like anything can go wrong in that fight.
That's a very,
David
didn't say it as a boring fight.
What he said was,
man,
the way you,
the way you let go on him in that period.
You know?
Why don't you just do that every time?
Crazy.
I said,
Dana,
when I let go is because I see the opening when I see it open and you will
always know me to go tell me one time I've seen opening and not went and I had
somebody hurting.
I'm not trying to finish it.
Don't you think that does?
Just frustration for someone who's not fighting,
who says things that aren't logical to you as a guy who was a champion,
who is fighting?
It's,
these are people saying what?
His Dad,
but as damaging witness to president when the president says it,
especially when you got the cultish following,
whatever he says is going to go.
If they say,
Damien Maia was born everybody,
and they're not making machines where if he say Tyron Woodley in Damien Maia,
all my God,
that fucking fight was boring.
Somebody goes,
sweet,
Tyron Woodley,
Damien Maia.
Oh my God,
that fucking fight is born.
They're not even gonna change a word.
That's what we have.
So as a champion and in a position of being supposedly being promoted at that
place,
it becomes damaging.
So now how are you going to come back and say,
okay,
towers back,
it showed us fix.
He's wanting to fucking most devastating guys out there.
You know,
knock your mother fucking head off.
But then five minutes ago you just say he was born and you know what I mean?
It's,
it's very hard.
I see what you're saying.
We're not talking about two different things.
What you're saying is you feel like the way they talked about you after the
fight was damaging and she was respectful and and also not accurate in terms of
the consequences of your actions in the fire and nobody ain't,
nobody came through.
I was like,
Damn,
you know what?
At to find out this motherfucker,
Tory has gotten them labor room in the first round and he still didn't give a
one damn takedown,
didn't hardly get touched at all in the entire fight.
Maybe Punch two or three times total.
And that's kind of clutch she's motherfucker got,
he must got fucking strong.
You would like to hear,
no,
I don't want to hear anything because I want to fight.
But you're saying,
you're saying,
I'm saying,
I'm saying that,
I'm saying that it was a choice made to say one thing but,
but it was also lies off the cuff.
Right.
And that's always been the thing about them,
but it's also you can also fly off the cuff in the other direction.
You can also say,
hey,
this person's fucking next superstar.
I'm a guy.
And gone was crazy.
Oh my God,
Cody Garbrandt his fucking the man.
Oh my God.
Page van Zandt.
This on my main says York cut that you can say that and what's what happened to
the 2 million followers?
2 million followers and that makes a big difference.
But that can happen to you at any moment.
You were frustrated by the reaction to three particular fights.
You definitely,
you want me to be fresh settled down fella.
I know.
I want to tell you to secret.
I'm working like hell right now.
I know you are and I'm not for sure.
I know you are.
I'm doing a lot of automotive work,
unhappy with certain things and this unhappiness stems from the result of three
fights.
But if you look at one fight before that,
the Robbie Lawler fight,
I mean everybody was talking about you lucky with the most devastating thing of
all time.
The fact that you were able to do that to Robbie Lawler,
all you need is one or two more fights like that kind of forgets about Damien
Maia.
You what happened?
You
want me to be,
no,
I don't.
Well,
let me tell you this.
I definitely don't,
I'm really not frustrated him.
Okay.
Now he playing cool guy.
I see.
I'm not frustrated.
I just know my deck of cards and I got a very thick layer of skin and I'm very,
I'm very cautious of who I am and my brand.
Now when you
do the division right and you're a champ,
you're at the top of the food chain,
what do you see in front of you?
Like what,
what threats,
what,
what fighters do you think are present unique challenges?
None.
Well,
what do you think is next for you if you just forget about the supervisor?
I think the deck needs to be shuffled.
And I think when I come back,
uh,
I think what,
I'll come back,
I take that back.
Carlos Mendez is dope.
He's frigging,
he's fighting this weekend,
tomorrow spoons and Mario says Batman
and he's a guy that a lot of people are not talking about
straight forward for a lot of reasons.
And I'm okay to talk about it because,
you know,
I've always been honest.
He's very tough.
He's a good style match up for me,
um,
to present a lot of challenges.
He's a good wrestler.
He's very strong.
He started to come along with his hands and I like,
if I'm a fight somebody and it's on some number one contender shit shit,
I want to fight somebody.
I respect somebody like Rda,
somebody like,
Ooh Smith till pots and evo does these dudes are,
these dudes are savages.
And you know,
not to sound cocky,
but I think my toughest challenges are behind me.
I think Carlos Condit and Robbie Lawler and at the time and costs check was
almost a few fights,
you know,
way from fighting George.
And you know those guys at that moment,
those guys presented a lot of problems.
Kasha kept the same overhand right.
Just a little bit different wrestling,
Great Chin.
I'm great conditioning.
A lot of experience.
You know,
it was a,
it was a threat for me.
Robbie Lawler was a fighter a year back to back.
You know,
it has some of the craziest fights we've ever seen in fucking lip hanging open
and he's bleeding and that's to do it.
I had to walk and he was a Boogie man at the time.
So for me to get bubble guts,
don't nobody have that power.
Then Nate Marco did.
When he knocked me the hell out.
I'll never be hit that hard again in my life.
Think Colby Covington cause he's gonna Punch me and make me like went and back
up.
Now look at how he was punching me and Maya,
it was a rabbit punches.
So if you don't have great wrestling,
great wrestling defense,
great conditioning and powering your hand,
you're just not going to give me butterflies.
Well,
I think for sure you have accomplished some great things and fought some amazing
fights against some very dangerous challenges.
I mean,
there's no doubt about that.
No one could deny that.
And those fights that you did just talk about Carlos Condit,
particularly Robbie Lawler,
Josh Koscheck in his prime,
amazing fights,
great results.
But when you talk about [inaudible],
we talk about Rda,
you talk about Darren till you're talking about also potential amazing fights.
You know,
I think there's a lot of outstanding opportunity and I think your divisions,
one of the most talent rich divisions in the sport.
I'm not discrediting that.
I think that I'm always a forward thinking dude.
So the teal guy didn't sneak up on me.
Neither do you saw till in advance.
You saw him.
I'm going to tell you,
I do this right.
At one point in time,
it was Brandon thatch.
It was Eric silver.
It was,
um,
Kevin gas alum.
It was Stephen Thompson.
Okay.
Brandon Thatch,
Eric Silver,
kind of doing it the way gasoline went up and fought me.
Stephen Thompson went up.
So now these the,
the Darren till the [inaudible] man.
All those guys during that same pool.
So I'm always thinking about training.
I was thinking about fighting these guys always game planning for these guys
before they even come up at some point.
I don't have to fight everybody cause they got,
they going to cancel each other out.
If it's five studs,
I might walk into three of them.
So I got to be ready.
Damien Maia wasn't a surprise.
I asked for Damien Maia,
I fought Jake shields or somebody,
somebody I fought and my manager was like,
dude,
why are you going to fight Damien?
Maia may suck at such a bs and this is this,
this and now I'm like,
I know this on paper,
Rory Mcdonald's,
my toughest matchup in the division right now.
Okay.
Even when Ellenberger was a stud and was fucking wrecking people because of his
power,
his wrestling and his condition,
him and Johnny Hendricks also would have been a threat.
What guys?
Where I was trying to fight,
let me get Johnny Hendricks for foreign former champion.
We're even Donald.
So I was going up against the guys,
Carlos Condit still today might be my favorite fighter.
So when I watched his video,
I was getting bottom like this motherfucker good.
I was still in his techniques,
but what happened when I fought him?
Did he look like the same quality county?
He looked,
no,
I punched him.
He looked like a ratchet was snatching them across the,
you know,
across the octagon.
It wasn't like I just kicked him in the knee and all my God,
he was going to win.
No,
he was getting dominated that fight because I did my homework.
I respect him that much that I took all his tools and I left him naked out there
in the octagon and he had to deal with my suite and he had deal my power.
That's what I do to everybody.
Nobody sees it.
They think I'm just just strong ass fucking wrestler with a hard right hand.
But look at the way that Jordan me and looked against me.
Look at the way the Teryx happening.
I all short Paul Day,
the Kelvin Gosling is never looked like that.
It gives anybody else.
Same thing with Steve and same thing with a Maya.
Same thing with Condi.
And same thing with Robbie is not,
it's not a surprise.
That's the way that Duke in Dean and I,
we,
we address what we,
if I'm fighting me fight tower in this way,
take them to the late round,
kick his leg,
stay away from his power circuit.
It's way.
So now I'm gonna formulate my game plan about what I think you think of me.
Then I think about every fucking thing that you do,
every skill,
every talent,
every mannerism.
What you do when you get tired,
what you're going to go to,
what's your bread,
butter.
And I get ready for those and it's sometime it's like Robbie took a long time.
It took up until the week of the fight for me to be like,
I got this motherfucker.
And what was it?
There was different.
He just punched really awkwardly.
He punched his arms are way longer than what you think.
Um,
he,
he's,
he's got way better boxing then when you think he doesn't look all like,
like you see somebody slipping the stuff.
Um,
he,
he threw a lot of unorthodox overhand lefts and upper cuts.
And right kicks,
which makes it very difficult to slip offline and throw any punches.
He was scrambled first shot,
if you shoot a shot,
he'll scramble you hard.
You have to shoot two,
three,
four attempts to get him to the ground.
He had one butterfly that he used to sweep to get off the ground.
So we just knew all that.
And then at any point he can play rope a dope and then he can come off swinging.
So that's a lot of things to think about.
And then he just can stand here like this and go boom.
And you knocked out.
Not Technique,
not turning the hips.
He just had heavy hands naturally.
So thus all was a threat and we've seen them in wars,
he's not going to go away.
So I had to,
you know,
formulate a game plan that I can get around all that.
Now when you saw the RDA,
Robbie Lawler fight,
you said that you weren't really impressed with that fight because RDA had him
against the octagon and he was 10 off of 30,000 punches and he didn't knock him
down and he didn't hurt him.
He was basically just punching the punch.
Anytime you punched the punch,
he wasn't your energy.
Well,
he's going up in weight and he's more volume now than he was when he was
fighting him.
Rda Five.
Yeah,
I think it's fine.
Hey,
you here now we're energy me when you get here now,
I mean if you,
if you make the jump,
you make the jump.
You know,
you can't be like,
I'm on.
I was aware I was a lightweight and now he's a welterweight,
but his style is different than especially a guy like you throws this.
This is my thought on Ravi.
Okay.
A lot of people I picked Robbie apart in,
in,
in the film room before I even followed them.
And the fight was over with before the fight started.
Robberies starts out the first 30 seconds,
extremely hard.
He ends the first,
second,
30 seconds,
extremely hard.
Second and fourth round of Kinda close.
He's going forward.
You're going forward.
He'll take something to give some.
Okay.
They're right.
He used to takes off.
You ever notice that he gets,
he gets a case,
he's confident.
His defense.
He'll let you punching and he'll block you.
Okay?
He wants wastes a lot of energy so he can get into that second gear.
It's not that he's so well conditioned why she's fighting against Carlos.
Why should his fight against Roy Watch his fight against Rda.
He spent that same moment against the octagon where he allowed the opponent,
the punch at him.
The same thing with Johnny.
Then he came off trying to get to in the burn themselves out.
It's very smart,
but if everyone would act like he just freaking marathon runner and he's not.
So when that happened,
I said,
okay,
you got to get on Robbie Hart.
You got to get a rabbit quick.
He's been punched a lot.
Like I did all every fucking statue.
You can take a hair,
raccoon,
the fighting omics.
The guy hit me up saying,
Robbie has a flat face.
You punched fat face.
He's used to absorbing those punches.
Go around the side,
punched him on the jawline.
Kind of crazy logic.
As a man,
I'll use everything.
I can tell you how many times he stepped to the fucking left during a fight.
How many times you throw his right hand versus left hand.
So you know,
I've been really secretive about a lot of this stuff because most people just
see me as an athlete,
they just punch hard as a good wrestler that you know that's tough and you know,
you know good game plan.
But I really overly get obsessed with studying my opponents to the point where
when Mazda I fighting Wonderboy,
I'm like,
he about to do this,
he about to do that.
He's throwing this,
he set this up,
look towards you.
There you go.
Oh he bought did it.
And everybody looking at me like,
how the fuck do you know what I say?
You motherfuckers watch that fight that I followed them and you thought it was
so easy.
Get Yo ass in there.
And that one,
the boys,
so one of the boys a g and he,
he can take a punch way better than I thought.
I hit us as hard and he went out three or four times and he just had the
mentality,
I'm not going to lose her then I'm not going to lose today.
And he was rewarded for that effort or just saying,
you know what,
I'm going to give it all I got and um,
he'll forever have my respect.
But at the end of the day,
you gotta be able to be honest with yourself.
I'm honest with who I am,
what I do well,
I'm not the best at elbows.
Can I throw elbows?
Yes.
But am I going to sit out there and act like I'm,
you know,
Matt Brown and somebody?
No,
that's his still Matt,
Brian and goes storm.
You're across the octagon like I will.
So once I see what I do well and I,
you know,
I can hide my weaknesses behind my strengths.
I can allow my opponents never to put me in a spot where they're going to have
the advantage to Damien Maia ever put me in a position where he had me in his
half guard.
No,
never did it.
But you still,
you didn't think that RDAs performance against Robbie Lawler was impressive
because he overwhelmed Robbie.
I mean,
he had turns,
turns I'm going to fight.
I don't know,
thinking mitre.
I tell I from a time thinking about,
from a tactical standpoint,
I thought find out.
I thought he had some really good success with low kicks and I thought he kind
of abandoned that.
I was kind of surprised that he didn't do that.
And um,
then I,
I saw Robbie do the roper dope.
But Robbie never came off normally.
Like I said,
Robbie take some punches to,
he'll come on storm.
You never came out of stone or maybe it was because he messed his leg up or
whatever.
But just from,
from two people that they want to say he's gonna fight me next,
let me fight somebody.
And it's a DDS hurt.
Lawler fought
RDA.
Seriously injured.
Now those injuries have been revealed.
Let's see what we got here was to say,
um,
destroy blew his ACL and meniscus and every other thing that's in your knee out
in the third round said wobbled over to the fence.
So it makes sense.
Yeah
they sent it cause cause,
cause if Robbie is notoriously known for,
you know,
like think about when Rory had him against the octagon with collars Kinda.
And he comes out and he comes out blasting.
But it's so I,
since it said he hurt himself before the fight though,
other article I was going to pull up,
but I found that that said,
yeah,
he was injured going into the fight.
Who tore his ACL before to fight during the fight.
Find that,
well it said that,
the title of that though,
go back to that real quick.
The title of it said who was seriously injured going into the
fight,
right.
Injured and then the entries have been revealed.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So that's it.
I think that was had to throw round,
right?
Yeah.
Right when you were saying that he lays off.
So,
so,
so he,
so he didn't,
he didn't come off all you,
you can't go to a thread on the forum posts.
That's at short.
You can't go to the thread on as well.
Nobody,
but yeah.
You know what,
that would make sense.
I'm
used to Robbie coming off and getting those 32nd bursts.
Like,
I don't know exactly.
Not talked to big John about this for a while about the judging.
Right.
And you know,
damage being landed.
So some of those fights where even if Robbie wasn't the more active one,
he's damaging people more cause he punched.
Pardon?
Is more aggressive.
But how can Carlos condit control the fact that he just don't punch his hardest?
Robbie,
you know,
she'd be pissed off.
Did you think he beat I'm rubbing in a fight.
I'd have to go back and washed out again.
I thought it was at that time.
At that time.
Did you think it,
I don't think I did.
I thought,
I think I thought that Hendricks did or that Robbie did.
Just enough to win.
What did,
I'd have to go back and I'd have to go back and watch it again.
I thought at that moment that Carlos one,
but I wasn't like,
oh my God,
I can't believe they gave him some Robbie,
but it was extremely close.
You can make an argument for either guy wouldn't put Robbie because he landed.
The more harder can talk harder punching it looks scarier.
I think that's why he got denied.
That means something though.
I mean,
uh,
someone who hits harder,
it has more damage.
That damage should be accumulated.
I mean that should be somewhat so up.
So someone's throws punches in,
it looks like it's effecting the person more.
Even if the other person throw more in landmark,
then the person is landing the damage and punches.
You think she went.
I think damage should count for more than punches.
It don't damage.
So like if one person has that the way that they supposed to score now,
currently,
I don't know.
I mean the new,
it's what's interesting is Nevada still doesn't accept the new rules.
They need to get the crane ones right before they tried to bring in the new
ones.
Yeah.
But what's also interesting is the scores are much wider now.
Like you see a lot more 10 eights now than the other side before,
which I think is good.
I just think that we're our system taking a system from boxing that only uses
hands and applying that to take down some mission attempts.
Leg Kicks.
You would almost have to know this guys,
is you get to world champion.
The fact that this guy swept him,
he should score more because this guy,
this is,
you know,
real house,
but nobody's going.
No judge is gonna have that,
you know,
insight.
I think it should be a much broader system.
I don't think it should be 10 points at all.
I think you're dealing with extreme amounts of variables.
It should be like almost like a hundred point system.
The guy that raft my fight against Wonderboy the first time,
the one that,
um,
was one judge,
they gave a 10,
10,
eight the first round and the ten nine the fourth round,
fourth round is when I knocked him down three times.
Yeah.
The ten eight was when you almost got him in the gay teens.
Is that why he no,
no,
no.
That,
I was getting McGinty and in the fourth round.
Yeah.
And he said,
well,
why did I think you almost kind of in a gay the first round in the first fight,
the first fight,
the first one I just ground and pound the hell out of him.
I took him down.
And as you beat him up for the whole round,
um,
he gave that round a 10,
eight or so.
It was the fourth round where you got them in the gift.
The fourth one is when I knocked them down and knock them down again,
I knocked him down again and then I went for the get tank,
knocked him down three times,
and then we forget to you.
And the judge told me,
he said,
you know,
I thought it was a 10,
eight round,
you know,
but then you wasted a minute and a good team wasted a minute.
They told me now that I had just got over this shit,
right.
I was,
I was just fucking said that said that I had just got over the fact that I felt
like it was some bullshit.
I got over that fact.
So,
you know,
whatever it is what it is,
let's do it again.
This time I'm fucking beat him.
This motherfucker walk up to me,
not even know who he is.
Say,
man,
I just wanna let you know.
I just your fight and um,
you know,
I'm the one that gave you the ten eight in the first round and tending to
fourth,
Ron did all of a sudden my insides just start burning and then he's like,
you know,
I just want to explain to you why.
You know,
cause I don't have a problem with,
you know,
facing the fighters afterwards.
You know,
you did well,
I was going to give you a 10 round,
you know,
it was crazy and you know,
but then you wait wasted a minute and to get to him,
I said,
sir,
let me tell you something.
I said the first round,
if you would have said 10,
900,
okay,
I ground upon our bloodied him up.
He didn't show,
no offense,
10,
eight,
nine,
whatever you want to give it.
I'm cool with that.
And I said the fourth round,
I knocked him down three times and I said,
I want to tell you a good team choke is not a,
um,
it's not a waste wasted.
It's not a move that you can say,
I wasted time and it's a finishing move.
Heady ty.
Ty had,
he's fucking tapped out.
The fight would have been over with.
So the fact that I tried to knock him out,
then his neck became available to my arms.
Then I grabbed his fucking neck and then I tried to choke him out.
Then he popped his head out.
Yes,
he's tough for making it through the whole onslaught of me trying to kill him.
But does that give him an extra point?
He said,
but then he threw some punches.
I said,
go back and watch the fight.
he threw a few punches from top.
How many landed?
He said,
oh no,
no.
I said,
sir,
I'm said,
I'm over the fight.
I'm glad they didn't say I lost the fight,
but the only significant damage that was landed in,
if I came from me,
the only knockdowns only,
you know,
blood drawn,
the only jeopardy of someone,
the referee getting involved happening when I was on the other end of it.
So I just think the system sucks.
I really think the scoring system,
they just don't let it go to the judges
that,
you know what?
Fuck it today.
I'm gonna let it go.
Hey,
you know what?
I'm not going to try to knock to,
I know I trust them three right there.
I look very trustworthy.
I'm going to leave it in their hands and all my kids and my family and my belt,
I'm gonna just,
you know,
I'm living up to them.
I always hate that expression.
I hate it because it's so,
some guys don't want to be finished.
Most guys and Steven's case would've,
would've,
would've been overweight.
Um,
you know,
some guys just talk,
I mean,
I don't want to just refinished,
right?
Nobody does snow.
It's a foolish way of looking at it.
It's just the best way to fight is the best way to fight.
And if you see an opening,
like you said,
that's when you move your idea that you're supposed to just rush into danger and
that's how you lose.
And the fact that people don't,
that and that people say things like that and they don't understand what they
really shouldn't be talking about.
Fighting.
Fighting is a complicated thing,
grinding thing.
And it's also,
it's one sport where it's like if the team doesn't run the ball well they don't
run the ball.
They pass.
So if this is Stephen Thompson,
he doesn't have to wrestle.
He doesn't have to try to do Jujitsu,
he just have to stop you from doing it to him.
But he's got that style that's impossible to find anywhere else.
Standing completely sideways.
He's throwing front leg kicks that can knock you out and social,
a lot of weird stuff.
And he bends at the waist like a snake.
He leads all those years of point karate,
like he's really fascinated too.
It's very good kick to Raymond Daniels,
which is a painted as sage Northcutt,
which actually in my opinion,
sparring wise was way harder than the Wonderboy.
More MMA experience for sure.
And also sidekicks ages,
his sidekicks,
he knocked,
I had the word Taekwondo Pat,
despite his age,
he kicked me to it.
If it's on my,
my bad,
Mr Woodley,
I'm like,
damn this motherfucker,
no joke,
no joke.
So He um,
he was good.
I had a kid named Chris Pang and from the same background that I had another guy
named Michael Tang,
who's the taekwondo guy from the,
from the east coast.
And then actually a lot of people don't know this.
Duke,
actually,
his original base was taekwondo.
So having all those guys,
it wasn't fun.
I mean it was,
it was many rounds.
I did not win.
I mean,
sage Northcutt kicked my ass for a couple of couple of days because I couldn't
figure out how the hell to get up on them without getting kicked in the
sidekick.
They now you've got to think about it like damn door.
How close to I get to him before he,
the side.
So,
you know,
it's a totally different style of movement and Wonderboy is probably the best in
the world.
He's good.
It's,
it's a very complicated fight and that's why I almost had an NVP out to me,
but he is,
his manager was trying to get too much money.
Michael Venom page.
Oh really?
I was gonna bring him out to,
he wanted to come out,
but his manager,
excuse me,
wanted me to bring him,
bring the manager,
bringing the friend,
you know him all this money and get them all three different separate rental
cars for,
I said,
I don't know the hell y'all think I am.
What kind of money I got.
But we not doing that for three days.
You made a big change in your life when you started training with Duke and a lot
of people don't know that before that you really didn't have like a main
trainer.
It's pretty impressive.
Dean's been with me for a long time,
but as far as a coach coach every day,
um,
I put myself through stuff.
That was all I was doing before Duke.
It was just me.
I had a gym.
I would say,
hey guys,
we're going to swap this time.
We're going to do this.
I will,
you know,
try to just my weaknesses that I've been really blessed to have the amount of
success I had without having a full time coach.
Then there's just got to the point where I told Dean,
I said,
man,
whatever it costs me or whatever,
I got to pay,
I need you the whole time.
I said,
because I can't do,
I've been winging and shit.
I can't keep doing that.
But what was interesting that you told me that it was son's idea file.
Yeah.
You got a good memory to go to Duke and take some notes.
No Hammer Shit.
Yeah.
My side,
I had,
um,
who was doing an embedded thing and it was like,
so where are we going tomorrow?
And I was like,
damn,
like either tomorrow is so on a humbug and like we ain't gonna fly to Florida.
I mean dean or are we going to drive to Milwaukee in the end?
My,
my,
my son Darrin,
he said,
I think you should go to Florida quip turn tray with Ben asked aspirin and
Anthony Patterson,
those guys.
And I think you should go with me.
Milwaukee.
Yeah.
So I said,
we woke up that morning.
I said,
fuck it,
we're going to Milwaukee.
So the embedded guys,
they,
they actually had to drive my car.
I was getting tired and falling asleep.
So the embedded guys driving my truck up there and we went up there.
This is code negative 14 degrees.
I was like,
man,
this sucks.
I'm coming back home in a week.
I brought eve out there who ain't never been in the colon in his life.
He's acting like he was going to die.
But um,
yeah,
I went out there and then Duke is always invited me to come out.
And you don't invite a lot of guys.
But Duke from Ben,
from Anthony always saw those guys killing south Pauls.
And after I talked to Duke,
now I understand Duke's brother was a south pole.
So his main sparring partner,
he learned all the tricks on how to defeat a southpaw.
So I'm like,
how did Anthony and all these guys,
every time they go and get somebody on the opposite stance,
they did great against him.
So if you do the math,
everybody I fought the battle had seven fights,
man,
South Pole,
Robbie,
Wonderboy,
my uh,
I say Wonderboy again,
all go gas alum.
Don't young Kim,
all have been south pole and all difficult guys at South Park.
And guess what?
Everybody else in front of me,
you saw Paul Rda,
Robby was salt,
Paul [inaudible] and South Paul.
So you got,
you got all these guys that are solid Paul.
So it made sense for me that only that he mates fighting fun again,
I wasn't having fun with it.
He made it fun to learn.
I felt like a kid again and you know,
it was a great morality,
Cim and you know,
it was,
I felt very specific to where I was doing.
I felt like I wasn't doing any training,
just pushing slash and flipping shit just to say I did it.
Everything had a function and I felt better and I look better.
And you know,
I did all this training.
I was renting my fucking self into the ground,
doing all this,
you know,
three,
four day trainings and looking all crazy.
And I got into the octagon and it never showed.
People were like damn man,
tiring,
I don't got their muscles.
You got all those Muslims,
motherfucker might get tired.
So I'm like damn,
I'm doing all this extra work but it ain't showing an octagon.
But then I started training with dude and then and they forced me to Tyron,
trust us,
you're doing too much.
And it's not,
if you're a sparring is affected because of your strength and conditioning,
it's no longer a supplement is taking the primary and we're not in fucking
crossfit in fighting.
You're sparring is number one.
Anything.
It takes your aspiring to be the best.
That's what we gotta do.
So we've got to run more or do less than as conditioning.
If we got to actually do none,
just spar.
If we gotta like there's been times I go in there and have a shitty sworn day
and I said I'll see y'all in the morning.
We doing this again,
we run it back.
Cause in the practice room you can run it back in real life you can't.
So I take advantage of,
you know,
the playground.
If you've been practicing.
I think now I just love fighting again.
I love training.
I love competing.
I Love Winnie.
I love that minute.
Well,
you know you won.
Now how much time do you spend in Milwaukee?
Do you just move your whole camp there with cardio?
Most of the time
I had to spend some time in Florida because I'm Damian my,
I'll be a complete idiot if I didn't take a part of the Brazilian jujitsu black
belts at American top team.
It really depends on a fight.
I,
I usually try to get at least four weeks.
We Duke,
the good thing about Duke,
Duke doesn't have a huge ego and he knows what he does well,
but he works well with other coaches.
That's why him and um,
Dean has been such a great dual,
if I need to bring in another striking coach,
so another training partner or somebody else,
he opens up the door for that because at the end of the day,
the goal is for me to be the champion,
a state champion and reached my goal being the greatest welterweight of all
time.
So smart guy.
If there was not for that,
then it be a little bit difficult.
And also Dan lamp,
you gotta realize I've been in American top team since they won.
Dan Lambert has never been in a blue about where I'm training at,
where I'm going.
I've always caught him and for him to give me the ability to go and get stuff
from other coaches is also been very helpful.
No,
he's another amazing guy,
too.
Valuable guy in MMA.
You think about the amount of money that he spent on American top team before he
made any money.
I mean,
that guy poured money into mixed martial arts.
He boarded into it and created one of the greatest facilities on the planet
earth for MMA,
especially the new place.
It's saying he's great too mean.
But,
uh,
as a coach,
what I really respect about Duke is not just the fact that he's got this
incredible wealth of knowledge,
but that he's so humble.
He's so like down to earth and chill.
GSR are the people,
the people that really just know it.
They don't have to prove it.
Days like that.
Duke's like that.
Um,
Lammers like that.
Some guys had overly want to show you and stuff.
Those are the people that are kind of insecure or where they add as cautious
striking coach you,
I mean you shared was writing coach,
she's all why you train with that guy?
They like get so sensitive.
I'm never seen it before.
Yeah.
So I just,
I just don't like to deal with it.
Yeah,
it's unfortunate.
It's not my boxing coach like that too.
Eric Brown for wild and I've been training with him since 2007 2008 so he's the
same way.
So now when you're out here,
like sometimes you're home and when you're home,
what kind of stuff do you do?
Like if you're not injured,
if you're not recovering from a surgery,
like what,
what stuff do you do at home and hang out with my kids.
Go to football practice,
go to the practice,
take everybody to school,
pick everybody up.
Play video games.
She went about like training.
I don't train.
You don't train it home sometimes.
Not much.
Really?
Yeah.
You don't do anything?
I do.
Shouldn't the condition it with my God dairy,
Fairchild
and um,
I got a,
I got a up and coming,
um,
featherweight.
There's really fast and good boxing so I play around with him a little bit.
I might run,
I might hit the bag,
might do the versaclimber,
but when this camp time,
my mouth,
when it's not camp time,
I'm both family.
That's interesting.
So you don't,
you're not constantly training?
No.
Wow.
That's you.
Do you feel like that used to,
you used to watch change that because I stopped like MMA.
Ah,
okay.
So now you feel like you were kind of burnt out but I never started watching.
I'm always watching film.
I'm always in my obviously working on Fox.
I got a break everybody down.
I wasn't burnt out.
I just,
I want to want to miss this shit.
I want to want to get back in there.
I want to hear somebody named,
they fighting me and I want to get nervous a little bit and watch some film and
see what they do well and then let's get this done.
Let's get this together.
Let's write everything out.
Let's map out the training camp,
let's get our partners,
let's do what we need to do and let's get after it.
And that,
that takes away the pressure from me right now with,
with his injury.
And the fact that three months in,
you should be able to probably start training hard.
What do you,
when you look in to defend the belt again?
You know,
I can probably,
I will probably fight,
um,
April will be kind of pushing it,
but may June,
July is use the card big July 4th car.
I shut away today.
That's a good one.
Yeah,
right.
By the way,
today,
and that's probably like more [inaudible] Saint Pierre fighting main event,
July,
whatever the hell we can.
July 4th weekend I used to be the international fight.
Yeah,
that's the bell would be,
I mean,
that's why I have the biggest chance to get a big fight.
That's what I want.
If I was your manager saying that's what we got to do.
So it was July,
probably hanging in the man.
It's no fight in between it.
That's going to make sense for me to do.
As George said,
he's retired or he's not retired.
What did they do?
Just just gave up the belt.
Right?
George?
I don't want to speak for George because I liked yours.
I liked them too,
so I don't want to speak for him.
But George is just smart.
He's,
he,
he plays the fact that he don't,
oh,
I don't really speak English that well.
Mother fucking smart.
He know what he done.
There's been wasn't right fight.
Okay.
Think about it.
Biz mean according to all the middle ways wasn't really the best middleweight
they all,
everybody wanted to fight Bisbing so if George is gonna go up fighting for
another belt,
another legendary move,
fight a guy that does not have the punching power,
maybe cannot take him down.
Maybe we can not stop to take down.
And for once George probably had a power punch,
a power advantage against Bisbee.
So with that said,
it made a lot of sense for him to do that.
They also had a lot of history training together.
That was a big part of it.
Yeah.
And George's eyes.
He was very successful again,
you know he was,
he was kind of worried about the size though.
Yeah.
He came and he was like,
hey,
so how much do you think gives me way?
I'm like,
are you fucking serious?
He was like really worried about that.
There was talk about you fighting Bisbing at one time.
I know you guys got with it.
We got back like two or five right now.
I'm good.
I'm good to find a middle way.
I actually offered to fight George had middleweight and give up my belt at
welterweight and just fight him.
If I lose the fucking middleweight title,
then I lost my belt and now I'm fucking Sam Sausage Cheddar,
you know,
I guess don't till the bottom of the bottom of the day,
but when you make that kind of ballsy say,
Hey,
I'll fight him at little weight and I would give my building.
It's that fight doesn't happen.
At that point I kind of feel like somebody might not want to mind.
Well,
it's hard to say,
right because the only fought once in four years and there's no timetable and
his return and no thought whatsoever.
There's a lot of weirdness in this sport right now.
It's so much rests on January 20th so much restaurant in Gando versus steep at,
because I think that fight is going to be gigantic for the sport.
It's going to be gigantic for the sport and then you know,
I think Steve pay his use of overly working in the over,
you know what I mean?
He,
he had the spot where he was like,
man,
when am I ever going get my shot?
And they finally got it took,
it took advantage of it and I was in a similar situation.
I was like,
when am I going to get my shot?
Got It.
Took advantage of it and Gyno has very scary.
It's so scared.
He know,
knock you out regular.
That's the thing.
You will hit you and you fall out.
He hit you and everybody,
oh sh they wondering if you alive still and it's kind of like,
like what he hit,
he hit ovary.
Oh my God.
Do you see the mean when it was like the,
like the Pez candy in his head,
his head,
his back of his head almost touch the spine.
That was an insane knock out.
Yeah,
he knocked him down.
He's freaky in his speed.
His power and his story's incredible.
I mean you want to talk about a story that's like right out of a movie.
Guy was homeless five years ago and now all of a sudden in two years of
fighting,
so appreciative and so happy,
you know,
fucking hands with like two times the size of my hand.
You say you're shake his head before feels weird.
Like you hook like you're shaking a loaf of bread.
I'm like,
Damn.
I told his boxing coach,
I'm like,
man,
I do not envy you man.
You get punched in their body protected.
I know that shit hurt.
He said,
no.
you can put it on.
I said,
no,
I will not tell them no,
not about that life.
He is something special.
The real world.
If I was Steve Bay,
I was walking down,
but he ain't going down.
It's going to try.
See if they got a good chin,
but I wouldn't test it against him.
No,
don't tell him.
I think he's going to try to close the distance and grabbed him and tried to
drag.
I think he should but I don't think he is.
You don't think it's going to be able to?
I think he wanted to show everybody.
I stood up with Overeem.
I sit over the um,
um,
jds.
I stood over for ratio.
I sit over all,
all these guys.
Totally different thing.
Right?
Nelson,
I know,
I know that wholly defined on his coaching staff.
I don't know what they think and I think he should punch the take downs,
take down on the ground and pound where his arms out and make,
make Ingando fight him to stop getting takedown and see if you can take some
steam off them hands.
That's what I think too.
And I think that the clinic is going to be critical over him.
Got The clinch on him but couldn't do anything with it.
And Stevie was college wrestler Steve Pay.
It's got good wrestling skills.
You know,
he's,
he's known more as being an overall well rounded MMA fighter,
but I think he's got to get that clinch.
I just think standing in front of in Ghana is just,
you're just,
you're playing Russian roulette.
One of those bullets is going to land in front of them and not even just in the,
even if we do an appearance,
I'm going to,
hey,
you too close to Miu Miu yo big ass over there.
Ooh,
Bingo.
When he connects it's just,
it's something different.
So people always ask me that.
Do you think they want in Gando to when do you think they are trying to set this
up so he can win?
Do you think like as far as asset,
he's an amazing story.
If he was the champion it would be very marketable and I don't want,
yeah,
I mean I don't know a firefighter with the raspy voice.
I don't think there's,
I think if Steve Bay can turn Francis back,
that's,
that's very marketable to I think the UDP lands he does when he gets to the,
he broke the record,
right?
Yeah.
He will break the record,
which is crazy,
but defenses.
I know that's how crazy the heavyweight division is and always has been.
You know,
all you,
the most anyone has ever done is Kane.
Kane's done two defenses.
Right?
Damn,
that's crazy.
Cane,
right?
Cain hold the,
the,
the office cane
and pork.
Kane Cain has so many injuries,
man.
It's just constantly injured.
That poor guy is constantly getting surgery.
Did he freaking my,
I know my man over there,
he's checking.
I thought she had a St Louis Hat.
I used to like to get some,
some stripes over there.
Now that La la and it's from Ohio.
Columbus,
Columbus are cold as hell out there.
Fuck out is,
I was just out in Canton not too long ago.
My son played in the hall of fame,
who I know UFC champion has defended the belt more than twice heavyweight
champion.
So what does it say?
Does it say,
um,
whether it's Cain,
Cain,
Cain Velasquez?
Yeah.
This is a while ago.
I think I'm,
Steve Bay is the version that came with less injuries.
Can't kicks a little bit more,
but you know,
just pressure Punchin um,
endurance.
Yeah.
Cause he plays the bass.
He's definitely a beast.
Look,
this is going to be the toughest fight for sure.
And in Ganas career,
but what's,
what's it mean if Steve Bay can win?
It's amazing and it solidifies his position as the baddest man on the planet.
But there's something about in Ghana that is,
it's uh,
it's more,
it's more enticing to people.
It's also the fact that Steve pay has been in so many wars and his chin has been
touched a lot of times.
Yeah.
So he has a great Chin but you don't want to keep testing it.
So she gets to do nick and Ghana would awkward power.
Yeah.
The five round junior dos Santos fight was crazy long fight and he got knocked
down who would go for a marine down.
So it's a tough one.
But the thing is like we,
we know so little about in Gannon was ground game.
We know so little about his,
his ability to overcome adversity.
Yeah.
He's just been smashing people.
Yeah,
I agree.
I said that.
I said that out of the day.
I think that Steve Hayes been in a tough fights.
He's been knocked down and he's,
he's on a five,
five,
five k I'll shrink as well,
like,
you know what I mean?
And it's against tougher opponents in Ghana was knocked out.
Well,
the sport is so exciting right now,
man.
There's so much talent.
Who's your favorite fighters going on?
Tyron Woodley.
It wouldn't happen to be because I'm here.
I don't have a favorite fighter.
Max Holloway smashing.
Right.
And I love Max.
I like his style too because his style is uh,
he overwhelms you.
He doesn't,
he's not knocking anybody.
I was one shot.
He's just constantly overwhelming you with conditioning and intelligence and
timing and distance and he could do everything.
He could strike you,
take you to the ground.
He's got a great defense.
Take taken submissions are outstanding and I liked that fight with him and
Frankie Edgar.
That's an interesting fight.
I was just talking about this other day,
but I'm,
Frankie Edgar has fought similar,
you know,
cub Swanson or Yoyo Rodriguez.
But Max isn't really fought anybody like,
like Frankie before somebody has short and compact that knows how to get close
quick,
knows how to get out quick.
He'll take it out.
Frankly,
don't give it here.
He was taken out.
Um,
who was at Charlie [inaudible]?
He didn't give me hell how great he was on the ground.
He was in his car punching and I think,
um,
that can present some problems.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Just to go fight the good fight.
Yeah.
That's the March 3rd fight.
And um,
Max is a big,
big favorite in that fight,
which I thought was functioning tall too.
He looks like he's in my weight.
Yeah.
He's tall.
Confident in the Aldo fight,
especially the second fight man.
You see that confidence just oozing out of him.
He's the champion.
He's a beast.
Yeah.
I think 55 is an amazing way in class right now.
We argue on Fox that they think they tried to get under my skin and say
lightweight is the best divisional said,
don't play with me.
Well,
two ways.
After a beep,
yeah.
Be was a beast.
I haven't watched any of his fights.
I watched him.
I said I need to go back to my,
um,
my math.
He fights like that every time.
Yeah,
he's a monster.
You see the Michael Johnson fight,
he's telling me to give up.
I saw that clear.
It must be jump,
give up,
smashing his wrestling and his,
his,
his ground and pound.
It's just so ferocious.
It's just on such another level.
And when he gets ahold of guys,
he's getting ahold of guys that are really good and just rag on him.
Like what he did the Rda Gypsy that fine.
Yeah,
I saw,
I haven't seen those fights.
I got to go back and look.
Ragdolled Rda.
It's just beats the shit out of people.
It gets you to the ground.
I was a big fan after that.
I'm like,
man,
he's something special dudes.
He's something special.
And the fact that he did that to Barboza he wants to move up to 72 shit.
No,
he don't.
Hey,
metabolic meals shit out and sit in and see my man.
He'll be by the pack.
Um,
nutrition.
Is anybody out there?
I'm picking up the tab cycle as down there.
55 I'm not trying to see,
no,
it could be right now.
He's making 55 easy now though.
So who knows?
I think what I believe is going to happen is I think Connor's going to vacate.
I think they're gonna strip him because Connor has got $100 million in the bank
and I think he's having fun and talking shit and he's going to keep training and
he's gonna make a big fight in the future.
But I think Khabib versus Tony is the big fight and fuck.
They might even do that one on Russia,
but they do that.
What they're talking about doing big fight in Russia that,
yeah,
if that happens,
that's a good fight.
I mean,
everybody's been waiting to see that fight.
Fuck yeah,
that's a good fun.
It's like Tony Ferguson.
Very Unorthodox.
How many wins?
He's got like nine or 10 in a row.
Yeah.
He has a the most ever in the lightweight division,
and I think it's at 10 I think when he beat Kevin,
it was at 10 Oh,
who do you lose with?
No,
Michael Johnson.
He loves to,
boy,
you gotta go way back.
He lost him a long time.
Maybe it was my first backhoe.
I mean Tony.
So Unorthodox and all the closer and against heave to Alcorn or at you for that
fight was a close one.
And he but man,
yeah,
he,
he just um,
nobody has told Tony at what he's doing is not who's Jamie?
Tony.
He's a,
he lost a Jamie Tony earlier in his career.
It was curled up.
What does that from a national fine lines.
Interesting.
The Hyatt regency.
Oh,
Karen Davidian.
That guy's a very good fucking submission artist.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Well he ain't OLED nine.
Tim have a good habits his then ah,
punch Cho Cho,
Cho Cho choke.
Yup.
And Ron and Ron and over guys to the Edson Barboza fight was fucking fantastic.
That was a fantastic loaded if I too,
I remember.
Yeah.
Well,
and that's the danger about by Tony.
It don't really matter if he's losing the fight the first,
the first or second round.
He keeps it together.
Yeah.
He's in my end.
The dos Anjos fight was amazing to beat the shit out of dos Sandro's that's it.
I mean,
he's a bad man.
Tony Ferguson,
you cannot sleep on Tony Ferguson.
I used to fight is amazing.
I used to be like,
man,
this dude striking don't look like it's something that should frighten me that
much.
But when it's coming so often it's so weird angles.
And then he's going for shots and he's,
he does the exact opposite of what you think you should do and grappling.
And then he's in the position and then we'd get there.
Now he's got like five or six schools for that position.
So he's like switching to here and there and there for,
you know,
y'all ass shot chucked out.
Yeah,
he's,
he's the real deal.
That's a,
that's an amazing fight.
I love that fight.
You know what I'm really interested in right now?
I'm really insistent.
TJ Dillashaw versus mighty mouse.
There's so much talking about that.
I don't know.
I want to see it though.
Someone's got challenged and I don't see 'em Garber and money mouth.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know why.
It just looks,
it looked on paper like I'm more interested in fight dom.
Man,
I disagree.
I think it's more interesting to see TJ.
Tj has got more
weapons like TJ does more stuff,
throws more kicks.
He's got more,
I mean you saw it in the guard band fight.
That's where he heard him.
You heard him when the head
I just,
I just like Cody's boxing in the pocket.
In his counters.
Yeah.
Anybody that's going to deal with Dj sp kind of big Dj miss and not very many
people who have been able to write.
So my think tank,
they both are going to be tough fights.
I mean it's going to be tough for,
Tj is going to be tough for Dillashaw mighty mouse.
He just has very few holes.
He's like pouring water is moving.
Just keep going to saying he never stopped.
I'm like,
Damn Dude,
I got to watch them drill.
We've raised fight.
Well I can do the same thing in the drill.
He just did it right in a fight.
Right?
Dang.
Now he's special.
Special.
His,
his ability and his ability to not get hit.
He's,
he's doing something
then that's,
he always thinks in dementia.
So like he was trying to take down Dotson,
remember in Dotson,
wanted them taken out and he said,
forget it,
I'm going to grab the leg and I'm a keep punching him in the face where elbowing
him in head.
And then finally he got to take now he just,
if he thinks is smart,
he's going to keep going.
Excuse me.
He's not going to get discouraged.
You're gonna keep going for it.
If he was going to get Tom who was a kid,
um,
Tim Elliot,
they had them in those days.
Chokes.
I'm like,
I was freaking out cause you know,
Dj Mohammad,
I'm like,
man,
is he about to loosen this kid?
And he said,
I'm good.
He had me in her deep,
like he just don't get ride over.
Oh no
rattled.
He's got the whole package.
She's got mental toughness.
He's intelligent.
His skill levels on another level.
I mean it's,
his skill level is off the charts.
He does everything.
He's a master at the shrine basics like that.
That's,
um,
lift up return on bar,
maybe one of the flashy name did you ever seen him do?
But in general,
if you think about it,
he comes forward and he does great fast basics from this side.
He sort of stands great pass Bates from that side,
very traditional clinch,
super active with it.
Um,
hard to take down,
gets up to regular way.
If he,
he'd mount shoot,
he believes like if of course teaches you or arm bar from the mouth and his
mind,
it's 100% chance it's gonna work.
There's no way it can't work.
So when you see him go do a regular arm bar on somebody and submit them like,
you know,
a whore or Gucci or John Moraga,
he's like,
Damn,
how you hitting him with that one bar?
Because he's just don't believe in the fact that doubt and his techniques.
So no,
it's a,
it's an amazing time.
Amazing time for the sport.
And uh,
I mean
it's amazing time.
It's just an amazing time for martial arts,
period.
I mean,
I think martial arts right now is at the highest level that it's ever been in
the history of people fighting each other.
No,
it's,
it's a a siding moment as well because now you got so many different hopefuls.
No,
we got six or seven people that they just need one more economy.
We just need one more.
This person is just need one more.
Then they jump off and it,
you know,
to become superstar because we,
we need more stars right now.
We got Connor,
but when this kind of going to come back,
I think Rhonda may do to WWE thing.
Josh,
she's done.
I'm pretty sure I figure WLV thing is a,
as a good look.
I know she was at,
at like dinner with triple h and m and our agent,
uh,
Slater.
So I hope she does that man because people can say whatever they want.
But Ronda Rousey was,
she was that girl at one point.
She was and she put us all on the map in a different way.
It had the old lady did the 75 year old lady at the airport talking about MMA.
So,
Yup.
She,
she,
she's a GG paid our,
do you know,
I think if she want to gracefully walk into a different realm,
WWE film I seen,
she's just produced some type of series that um,
you know,
we should support her on that.
I agree.
I agree 100% and really don't want to see her fight again.
I,
if she wants to fight again,
but what if I would,
I would want to see is her move to a camp that could address the entire game of
MMA in a much more comprehensive way and not tell her that she's great at
something.
If she's willing,
I would want her to go to like Matt Hume or someone like that.
But who,
who is she actually fight?
She's two.
She's too big of a name to fight somebody who she's fighting fight someone who's
coming up fight someone get a tune up fight.
You had an actual,
I mean,
but I don't even think she wants to fight.
I think at a certain point in time you have enough money in the bank,
you have enough notoriety and fame and she's got a lot of aspirations outside of
the sport.
She's married now.
Who knows?
She might want to start a family.
You right,
you right.
Listen,
all I want to see is George Saint Pierre versus was in July,
July four I say because my big prediction for [inaudible] make it happen big.
My big prediction for me is that I fight just any pair of my first fight back.
I'd like to see,
I showed us or I can hurt Katie.
We'll pause.
How do you sleep?
I can't punch it.
Hard to sleep.
I mean George is,
if you want to fight me,
brother,
this is the time and time Georgia get me George right now.
Wake up money George.
And what a fight that would be in terms of like,
like just historical significance and how big it would be.
I mean,
he's coming off of the win of his career coming back four years off beat Bisbing
choke them unconscious for the title.
Vacates the title steps right in their fights.
You at one 70.
He's a,
Gee,
it'd be fun.
And he would exit the sport and nobody would give him that much stuff from
losing to me.
Thanks for doing this,
man.
I appreciate it.
I'm glad we finally got in here.
So it did it.
Uh,
tell people,
what's your Twitter handle?
Check me out on Twitter.
Two
Oh d.
L.
E.
Y.
Same thing on Instagram.
And I'm,
yeah,
we out here
the champ,
ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you.
All right.
Hmm.